i think my idea of how creativity works
and stem jobs has
changed
since i've gotten to college like i used
to think that like all the
mathematicians would be just locked away
in some like office and like typing on
their computers or writing down
equations by themselves they coming up
with incredibly beautiful ideas just by
themselves but i'm realizing now that
i'm in college that
i mathematics and creativity it's a lot
about communication and it's a lot about
trying to build off of each other's
ideas and balance ideas ideas off of
each other
and builds upon um
ideas that have already been made by
people decades ago um and i think that
the facts that we all come with it with
our own perspectives and different um
ideas and different ways of being
creative create allows math to advance
further because we can all combine our
creative ideas into something bigger we
collect data on
everything right and so the ability to
use that data in a
smart safe and efficient way depends on
new applications of mathematical
concepts to these new and innovative
data sets
as we get to that point we'll start to
be thinking outside the box a lot more
and will be a much more innovative
digital society but that can't happen
unless we start trying to be creative
and not just rely on tried and true